в нас колосальна проблема в державі наші
військові не можуть отримати статус у БД
деякі які по року два роки на нулі
служать а отримати статус учасника
бойових дій не можуть в нас цим повний
бардак В принципі схоже з тим що
відбувається в Верховній Раді України і
це безумовно є абсолютно неправильно так
не має бути має бути надання статусу ОБД
автоматично Людина отримала один раз бо
доплату Значить вона приймала участь в
бойових діях Людина отримала не дай боже
поранення бойове Значить вона приймала
участь в бойових діях автоматично дайте
статус убд дайте людині цей документ це
була ідея цього законопроекту але далі
далі почалося кіно в нього повключали ну
просто все підряд Ну це неможливо навіть
голосувати такі питання і Ми не
розуміємо сьогодні що в цьому
законопроекті в ньому всього дуже багато
так не має бути